it's funny oh you you mentioned writing
everywhere young David you are one of
those children you wrote last first
didn't you no because I do think there's
some children who just kind of go yeah
but you bothered well I I remember any
other letters than this one but I wrote
a letter when there was a program when
place school was on you remember placing
all it was a program here for very young
children and it was like set in a
fictional house and then there was a bit
I think to try and help children learn
to tell the time where there was a clock
just before the story I think there was
a clock and you go down and there and
the thing beneath the clock would go
round and there would be figures on it
and it was quite magical
and then that stopped going round at one
point and I was told and maybe I'm wrong
about this but I was told it was because
of a union dispute at the BBC I mean I
think it was I think I would have been
five I don't think so but later was told
do you need this to anyone
totally was an argument and argument
between the people who did the thing
going round and other people like the
people who read the stories or that you
know and so I wrote a letter
I think vacuously suggesting that they
should have some sort of conversation to
resolve then to President Reagan I did
what was grinding your gears she well
she would just popped up one day and
said she wanted to write a letter to
President Reagan so the first thing I
learned how to read was the newspaper
probably not surprising in my house and
I read an article one day when I was 5
in the newspaper over my Cheerios that
I'd secretly put honey on top of because
my mother wouldn't let me have sugar
cereal she now spoils my children
grudge read that President Reagan was
going on a state visit to what was in
West Germany and he was going to visit
Bitburg cemetery and at Bitburg there
were Nazis buried there including
members of the SS leadership and I
didn't think an American president
should be going to pay his respect on
behalf of our country to a place where
Nazis were buried how old were you I was
five but I wrote a letter to President
Reagan and I said give her the honey
Wow from The Sound of Music okay okay I
wrote a letter saying you near dear mr.
president I've seen The Sound of Music
the Nazis were not nice people please
don't go to their secretary
[Music]
you